I'm about to sign into law
bipartisan safety measures, gun
safety legislation.
And time is of the essence.
Lives will be saved.
When it seems impossible to get
anything done in Washington, we are
doing something consequential.
We can reach compromise on guns.
We ought to be able to reach
compromise on other critical issues.
The new gun law is not an inspiring
example of bipartisan cooperation
to protect public safety.
It's an illustration of how the
worst instincts of both major
parties combine to produce policies
that are neither just nor sensible.
The bill passed the Senate by
unanimous consent and passed the
House with bipartisan support
because it offered something to both
sides.
Republicans got tougher sentences,
Democrats got more gun control, and
both got to pretend they were doing
something to prevent mass shootings.
The law is unlikely to have a
meaningful impact on mass shootings,
but it will cancel the gun rights of
adults based on juvenile records and
subsidize state laws that suspend
those rights without due process.
It also increases the maximum
penalty for gun possession by people
with felony records from 10 to
15 years.
That ban applies no matter how old
the conviction is and regardless of
whether the offense involved
violence.
The law created additional criminal
penalties of up to 15 years in
prison for trafficking in firearms,
which is defined so broadly that it
covers any prohibited person who
receives a gun.
Prohibited persons who are legally
disqualified from owning firearms
include millions of Americans with
no history of violence such as
cannabis consumers, former
psychiatric patients who have never
been deemed a threat to others, and
people convicted of drug crimes or
other nonviolent felonies.
Thanks to this law, a cannabis
consumer could go to prison for up
to 15 years if he obtains a
gun, even if he lives in a state
that has legalized marijuana.
That trafficking and firearms
penalty also applies to people who
have lost the right to own guns
under state law, even when they are
not disqualified under federal law.
These new penalties will
disproportionately harm
African-Americans.
Last fiscal year, 89%
of federal firearms offenses involve
illegal possession, often without
aggravating circumstances or a
history of violence.
55% of those defendants
were black. Even the American Civil
Liberties Union, which thinks the
right to keep and bear arms is a
figment of the Supreme Court's
imagination, recognizes that
the categories of people that
federal law currently prohibits from
possessing or purchasing a gun are
overbroad and not reasonably
related to the state's interest in
public safety.
The ACLU says those gun bans
raise significant equal protection
and due process concerns.
As an appeals court judge, Supreme
Court Justice Amy Coney Barrett went
even further, arguing that the
wildly over inclusive gun ban
for people with felony records
violates the Second Amendment.
Undeterred by such criticism,
Republicans who claim to support the
Second Amendment voted not only to
continue punishing people for
exercising the rights it guarantees,
but to increase the penalties they
face. So did Democrats, despite
their avowed concern about
excessively severe sentences, racial
disparities and the damage done
by the war on drugs.
This is what bipartisan compromise
means in Washington; I will
compromise my principles if you
compromise yours.